[Music]
we have democrat members of congress who
are with us four hours ago who are not
with us right now that should tell the
american people everything and so people
are going to have choices this november
is much more than politics this is
national security
democrats and republicans sparring over
president biden's board of crisis as gop
lawmakers get a first-hand look at the
crisis while democrats stay in d.c
congressman brian style was part of that
congressional trip he joins me now
congressman thank you for taking time
what did you see there and why
are the democrat colleagues of yours not
seeing it the same way
our democratic colleagues took us to the
united states border they wanted to talk
about infrastructure and investment they
continue to refuse to talk about the
crises the democrats are creating the
border crisis the inflation crisis the
crime crisis republicans on the
committee saw firsthand by going to the
border the problems that this
administration has caused over 3 million
3 million illegal immigrants have come
across the border since president biden
took office that's three times the state
of delaware its population we've seen
over 3 600 pounds of fentanyl captured
at the southern border that's 3 billion
lethal doses it's impacting cities not
only across the border but across the
united states of america and racine
county in southeast wisconsin 68 people
died of an illicit fentanyl overdose
last year the problems this
administration is creating at the u.s
mexico border are impacting not only the
communities of the border and we saw
that firsthand they're impacting every
city in the united states of america
in congress and literally our viewers
are looking at footage i shot on my cell
phone two weeks ago i was in that same
rgb sector where you were so i want to
ask you a tough question which i keep
asking all the lawmakers that visit it
and that is how can you fix it what can
you do republicans are in the minority
here but is there anything you think you
could do to help
fix the problem
what we need to do is send the message
that our border is no longer open
unfortunately the byte administration
continues to send the opposite message
that the united states border is open
and unsecure we have to look out to
november to be able to turn the tide on
this and to finally begin to rebuild the
wall you got to remember the biden
administration stopped construction of
the wall on day one then they passed
incredible inflation causing stimulus
programs with zero dollars for border
security and the 1.9 trillion dollar got
under the guise of covid zero dollars
for border security 1.2 trillion dollars
for infrastructure zero dollars for
border security the biden
administration's own budget cuts dhs by
800 million dollars we got to go the
other direction we got to fund the
border security it's absolutely
imperative and drawing attention to this
is needed
congressman you mentioned the word
inflation i want to quickly get that in
because janet yellen treasury secretary
yesterday said on the sunday shows that
a recession
is not necessarily inevitable this is
the same janet yellen who told us that
inflation was transitory she was wrong
about that she's about to be wrong on
the recession looking at history and all
the indicators is the administration
just lying to us at this point
the administration wants to continue to
put their head in the sand as it relates
to inflation we're way behind the eight
ball we got a big problem ahead of us we
need to do everything we can to actually
stop the runaway spending in washington
that's fueling the inflationary
environment that we see get spending
under control the administration wants
to do anything but we're behind the
eight ball we've got challenging waters
ahead of us hopefully we can hold off a
recession but it's going to take policy
changes in washington like unleashing
american energy to prevent a true
recession from coming
we shall see if that happens midterms a
lot of focus on the pain americans are
feeling at the pump and at the grocery
store and everywhere else brian sell
congressman thank you very much for
taking time this morning have a great
rest of your week
thank you